yeah uh White's queen wants to firstly  attack the black Bishop but also go to  the H2 Square in front of the white king  let's check and you hit the black queen  yeah as you mentioned Simon Quinn a  queenless end game it's an easy win for  white  so Magnus has to stop that idea  okay but now uh the bishop and the queen  are in a pickle they're tied up together  and of course you can't step back to  give a check because the queen would  block it so okay now's a chance to have  a you've got a free move  now is the moment to move a night friend  check mate why not exactly  there you go in checks and we do have a  result pregnantanda has taken it to  tybridge wow impressive oh imagine if uh  this would have meant he uh still had a  chance to win the FDX crypto cup he  still has a chance now to take second  player Play Store pragnananda a massive  win against the world number one